La vache, Manon. Tu bois beaucoup de café quand même. J'ai entendu dire que c'était cancérigène.
Bah, t'as vu ça où toi ?
Y a des études scientifiques qui montrent ça. Attend.
Le café, un bon goût de cancer.
Nan attend, onze raisons pour lesquelles vous devriez boire du café tous les jours.
En tout cas, c'est mauvais pour la santé.
L'Europe met en garde contre l'abus de café.
Oui, mais, trois cafés bio par jour, c'est bon pour la santé.
Ah non, en fait, le café, c'est le prochain produit cancérigène sur le radar de l'OMS.
Le café réduit les risques de cancer.
En tout cas, y a des raisons de s'en méfier.
Finalement, virgule, ce serait bon pour la santé.
Bon euh, qui veut du vin ?
C'est sur que si on se base que sur les articles de presse pour se faire une idée sur un sujet de ce genre,
on a rapidement une vision qui ressemble plus aux idées reçues plutôt que aux réelles connaissances scientifiques.
Mais se baser directement sur les articles scientifiques,
c'est difficile quand on ne connait pas trop.
C'est souvent compliqué a lire.
En vérité, ça ne s'adresse pas vraiment au simple citoyen,
comme moi, qui ne connait rien au sujet.
L'auteure, c'est une chercheuse ou un chercheur,
ultra spécialisée dans un domaine spécifique,
elle s'adresse à ses collègues qui font le même métier qu'elle.
Mais pourtant, il m'arrive de vouloir chercher une étude scientifique.
ne serait-ce que pour vérifier que la conclusion corresponde
au moins un peu aux affirmations sensationnelles que j'ai lues dans la presse,
parce que parfois les journalistes s'emballent un peu,
et l'opinion publique sur les réseaux sociaux s'emballe encore plus.
L'idéal serait que tout le monde puisse vérifier les sources, bien sûr,
mais je sais qu'on ne peut pas faire ça.
Il faut comprendre un petit peu l'anglais.
Il faut quelques notions de bases en statistique pour interpréter les résultats
Il faut savoir comment trouver ces études, parce que le mécanisme des publications, c'est pas simple.
Et ensuite, il faut savoir comment interpréter les résultats, c'est pas inné ça, ça s'apprend.
C'est enseigné à ceux qui sont destinés à devenir chercheurs,
Mais moi je ne suis pas chercheur,
c'est difficile pour moi de savoir seulement où chercher.
Dis moi Léa,
je suis toujours en train de faire des recherches sur le café.
Comment est-ce que moi, je pourrais avoir accès aux études scientifiques.
- Ah parce que tu n’es pas dans une université. C’est ça ?
- Non.
Oui, c’est vrai que quand tu es dans une université,
L’université, elle va payer pour que tous ses chercheurs aient accès à un ensemble de revues scientifiques.
Et c’est ça qui est complètement absurde, parce que les chercheurs,
ils paient pour publier dans les revues scientifiques.
Donc, ils paient en fonction du nombre de pages de l’article, du nombre de figures qu’il y a dans l’article, si c’est en couleur ou pas.
Et, en plus, l’université derrière, elle doit repayer des abonnements à ces revues.
- C'est ballot
- Ouais, et donc,
quand tu n’es pas dans une université,
tu peux quand même avoir accès aux revues scientifiques.
Tu vas d’abord chercher ton article dans un moteur de recherche qui va recenser
les revues scientifiques et les articles scientifiques.
Genre, je sais pas, Google Scholar, PubMed ou OpenEdition en SHS.
Après, tu vas pouvoir voir déjà s’il est en open access, c’est à dire s’il est en accès libre.
Donc, il y a des chercheurs qui paient pour que leurs articles soient publiés libres de droit.
- Ce serait l’idéal pour moi.
- Voilà, donc ça, ça existe.
Tu as aussi des sites qui recensent uniquement tous les articles qui sont libres.
Donc, tu as Archive, par exemple, y a HAL. H. A. L.
qui va aussi recenser les mémoires, les thèses, etc.
- Et, du coup, une fois que tu as trouvé ton article, si jamais il n’est pas en open access.
- Ce qui est souvent le cas.
Ça arrive, mais dans ce cas-là, tu as toujours le nom de l’auteur,
tu peux le contacter par mail, tu peux le contacter par ResearchGate, par exemple.
C’est un site sur lequel tu peux carrément demander : « est-ce que je peux avoir le PDF ? ».
- Il va me répondre ?
- Oui oui, et tu peux même les contacter sur Twitter.
Y a un hashtag #icanhaspdf, c’est même assez connu pour ça.
Et en général, bah, les chercheurs, ils sont contents que tu parles de leur article, que tu lises leur article,
y a aucune raison qu’ils ne te répondent pas.
- Je vais carrément faire ça. Twitter !
- Bah oui voilà !
Si mon journal est sérieux, il y a un lien direct dans l'article vers l'étude en question.
Ou au moins à la fin, une bibliographie utilisable, avec le titre, l'année et l'auteur.
S’il n’y a rien, moi je hausse les épaules et je passe mon chemin.
Le café est-il cancérigène ? S’il n'y a pas de preuves, il n'y a pas de raison de le croire.
Mais, les études scientifiques peuvent-elles être fausses ?
Il y a régulièrement des études scientifiques qui cherchent à mesurer la proportion des études scientifiques qui pourraient être fausses.
Et lorsqu'on cherche à reproduire à l'identique certaines études que l'on trouvait convaincantes,
les résultats ne sont pas toujours au rendez vous.
Certaines disciplines font en ce moment face à une crise de la reproductibilité,
c'est à dire que quand on essaye le même protocole, on ne trouve pas toujours les mêmes résultats.
Je vais essayer de faire une petite liste des différents cas de figure à garder en tête pour y voir plus clair.
Déjà, il y a les cas d'erreurs,
dues à une mauvaises manip, une étourderie, de l'incompétence.
Les scientifiques sont des êtres-humains pas des super-héros.
Ensuite, il y a déjà ces cas des fraudes scientifiques. Ça, c'est plus grave.
Parfois, c'est pour avoir des résultats intéressants, parce que pour un chercheur,
la quantité de publication est un critère pour l'avancement de sa carrière.
Les laboratoires sont bien au courant de l'importance de lutter contre ça.
Parfois, c'est parce que le chercheur a été payé par un lobby.
C'est pour cette raison que les conflits d’intérêts sont très encadrés.
Ces cas-là sont souvent décelés quelques temps après la publication, et l'étude est alors retirée.
Parfois, même les diplômes de doctorat sont attribuées de façon assez complaisante.
Si vous êtes une célébrité médiatique, mannequin et astrologue,
votre thèse incompréhensible a plus de chance d'être retenue que si vous étiez personne.
Et, ça marche aussi si vous êtes un animateur de télévision.
Et puis, j'essaye d'éviter de m'emballer face à un résultat inédit.
La moitié des études scientifiques relayées par les médias seront réfutées un jour.
La science, ça prend du temps.
Si la découverte est tout récente, c'est pas la peine de faire tout un plat sur la moindre annonce.
Mais au final, sur un temps long, la méthode scientifique reste la meilleure méthode que l'on ait.
Les chercheurs sont les premiers à s'indigner de ces cas-là,
et je les comprends, parce que ça entache réellement la valeur de leur titre de docteur dans l'opinion publique.
Pour repérer les revues complaisantes, qui publient les trucs plus en fonction du buzz plutôt que du sérieux méthodologique,
il y a les canulars scientifiques.
Ça consiste à écrire un article bidon, avec une méthodologie foireuse,
qui flatte la ligne éditoriale de la revue, mais qui ne respecte clairement pas les critères que l'on peut attendre de la science.
Par exemple avec des phrases qui n’ont aucun sens, du jargon inutile, une conclusion qui ne correspond même pas aux données,
et de soumettre aux revues scientifiques du domaine, juste pour voir si les comités de lecture sont vigilants,
et si l’éditeur accepte de le publier.
L'exemple le plus connu est celui d'Alan Sokal,
qui a proposé un article complètement imbitable, qui fut accepté à la publication dans une revue de science sociale portée sur le relativisme.
Il y a régulièrement des canulars qui mettent à jour des dérives, parfois rigolotes, mais toujours instructives.
Parfois, c'est dur de déterminer si l'objectif du canular
est vraiment de desceller des dérives, ou juste une tentative pour discréditer tout une discipline que l’on aime pas.
L'an dernier, l'affaire des canulars sur les Grievance Studies a fait couler beaucoup d'encre dans la presse.
Trois chercheurs décident de proposer aux revues scientifiques une vingtaine de fausses études pour essayer de les piéger.
Ils avaient ciblé exclusivement des études sur les stéréotypes, sur le genre, sur les mouvements féministes, car c'est un sujet très sensible.
Plusieurs études ont été publiées.
Mais dans les sciences sociales, les enjeux ne sont pas uniquement scientifiques.
Les objectifs politiques des auteurs du canulars sont donc aussi à prendre en compte.
Et enfin, et surtout, il y a les cas de faux positifs.
Une étude scientifique a même pas besoin d'être vraiment fausse, pour ne pas être reproductible.
Ça peut simplement être un cas où on a juste eu de la chance avec les échantillons.
Si j'ai, disons, une centaine de personnes volontaires, et que je demande à la moitié d'entre eux de boire beaucoup de café,
et aux autres de ne pas boire de café,
et que je surveille leur état de santé sur des années.
Parfois ceux du premier groupe sont en moyenne plus malade, parfois c'est ceux du deuxième groupe,
c'est aléatoire, parce que il y a pleins d'autres facteurs inconnus qui comptent.
Il y a les virus, les gènes, la chance.
Pour s'assurer que ca vient bien du café, les scientifiques calculent en priorité les chances
qu'on avait d'observer ce résultat si le café n'avait aucun effet.
Ce chiffre-là, on l’appelle la valeur-p.
Si il y a moins de 5% de chance que ce soit juste due au hasard, on conclura que ce n'est pas juste le hasard.
On dira que l'étude est significative.
Mais ça veut dire aussi que si tout se passe bien, sans erreur, sans fraude, ni corruption, et que le café n'a aucun effet,
alors 5% des études sont juste des faux positifs.
Du coup, s’il existe des centaines d'études sur un sujet, il y en aura TOUJOURS un certain nombre d’études qui "prouvent" que le phénomène en question existe.
Mais cette valeur de significativité est souvent mal comprise.
Les statisticiens arrêtent pas de mettre en garde les chercheurs contre ce genre de mauvaises interprétations de cette valeur-p.
En avril 2018, 800 chercheurs de par le monde ont publié une tribune pour appeler à changer les habitudes du monde de la recherche
sur ces sur-interprétations a propos de la significativité.
Ils insistent pour rappeler que ce chiffre
ne mesure pas les chances que le phénomène existe.
Il ne mesure pas la taille du phénomène.
Et surtout, il ne permet pas de décider si on doit accepter ou rejeter le phénomène.
Cette idée de rejeter l'hypothèse nulle est à l'origine de beaucoup de confusion, même au sein des chercheurs.
Les statistiques sont un domaine très facile à mal interpréter.
En attendant, le citoyen standard, pas spécialiste, comme moi, doit être sacrément prudent quand il lit que
«une étude a montré que»
et encore plus prudent lorsqu'il lit que «toute la science se trompe».
Merci à vous d'être aussi enthousiaste sur les sujets autour de la méthode scientifique,
elle est certainement perfectible, mais tellement passionnante.
On en parle dans les commentaires, ou mieux, sur le Discord du Vortex.
Et si tu aimes le café, envoie des pouces.
Apéro ?
Ça au moins, c'est pas mauvais pour la santé.